tuatanga by lower trying to get into the
nfl draft and he is hamstrung by the
reality
that there will be no opportunity for
any team to check out his hip for the
medical recheck that happens every year
except this one in indianapolis in the
middle of april for anyone who had red
flags at the scouting combine but from
his perspective his agent says he's fine
his doctor says he's fine now tuatanga
viloa says he's fine i feel 100 he said
via nfl network i feel like if there was
a game today i'd be able to go out and
perform the same way i was able to
perform in previous years i feel as
mobile as possible i feel 100
and that's not a surprise for a couple
of reasons first of all we saw a video
of him working out recently and he
looked fine
right but but look what what i i love
tua we interviewed him at the super bowl
great kid
what do we expect him to say exactly
what are we exactly any player to say in
this situation man i don't know if i
could do it right now i sure wouldn't
draft me
buyer beware baby i'm just telling you
you may want to think twice before you
put my name on that card
well i mean that's exactly right that's
the first thing i thought of i mean what
do people expect him to say here yeah
whether he's 85 percent 90 80
he's going to tell you right now that
he's 100 and ready to go of course he is
i mean yes he wants to be a high draft
pick he wants you know more financial
security so i'm not mad at him for that
and hey listen i hope he's telling the
truth i hope he is a hundred percent i'm
not mad enough he is fibbing a little
bit too and is 90
but yes this is going to be the big
question about tua yeah i mean when you
have that many injuries in college
football we know the nfl is bigger
faster stronger more aggressive more of
a grind on a week to week basis
quarterbacks get beat up and now you're
talking about a guy with an injury
history who plays small that's why it's
concerning that's why again i'm with you
i like tua i'm rooting for him he's a
fellow lefty quarterback but when i'm
just real about my quarterback
assessment you know that is something i
am going to go back to yes injury
history plays very small i don't think
he's overly fast or anything like that
to get out of harm's way all the time
he's got great feet to hop around um uh
but that that's to me mike why i've kind
of been beating the drum there's there's
just no way i would dr i would drop tua
in the top 10
of the nfl draft coming up here in a few
weeks because of all those reasons i
just stated
the immortal george costanza once said
it's not a lie if you believe it and i
don't think he's lying i don't think
he's fibbing i think he genuinely
believes he's 100
it's part of the bravado it's part of
that sense of invincibility that you
have when you're in your early 20s he
feels great he feels no different than
he ever has and it's easy to feel that
way when you're out there running around
the cones and you don't have pads on and
no one's chasing you he may feel very
different if he were on a football field
today against sec caliber competition
and he may feel incredibly different
when he's on the field in the fall
against nfl caliber competition and he
may want to revise his answer at that
point for now though i think he's
telling the truth yeah sure he he hasn't
been jaded and corrupted yet by the fact
that everybody in the nfl lies at some
point or another he's telling the truth
i just think he may not be
the best person to accurately assess his
overall health and you mentioned him
dropping and one of the most important
things an agent can do
when getting a player ready for the
draft is have the player understand what
his floor is what is the latest you're
gonna be picked and the best agents know
how to find out no matter what else
happens this team is taking you with
that pick and you're not going to fall
any farther than that what do you think
is floor is
well i think ultimately his floor would
be somewhere
you know in the 20s i think that's about
as far as he would fall i you know again
i still expect him to be a first-round
draft pick and i think he's certainly
worthy of that all i'm saying is you
know as far as projecting him in the nfl
yeah i don't think he's in justin
herbert or joe burrows class and i think
those are the only two guys that i would
say are top ten picks as far as the
quarterback position is concerned but i
don't think he would fall much farther
than that mike i mean you know i know
there's a faction of people out there
that love the way tula plays and
everything like that and i understand it
you know my big concern is hey it's easy
to look good at alabama too you know you
put me on the golden state warriors with
kevin durant and steph curry and you
know klay thompson everything i'm gonna
get eight or ten points a game on that
team because they're gonna be so worried
about no you know i i i can shoot threes
i'm a good three-point shooter okay so i
feel like i'd be open a few times now
you put me on the memphis grizzlies with
no help i'm gonna get two points that's
all i'm trying to say there a little bit
you know i hear people sometimes with
tua and herbert comparisons they go man
i wish herbert would just let it rip
like tua does and i want to say
well okay i hear you but i want someone
to go it's easy to let it rip when the
first guy you look at is wide open every
time too and i don't think everybody is
taking that into account when it comes
to tool but i do think no less than the
the low 20s really mike as far as that's
as far as tua could fall in in my eyes
i've just got this image of you playing
basketball just shooting and shooting
and shooting one of those guys that just
constantly is chucking it up not giving
it to his teammates it's all me
left-handed jay here you really think
i'm that kind of guy you really think
i'm that kind of guy i was very good i
was very when i was young i was a ball
hog okay but when i got to like eighth
grade
high school i played the team game i
wasn't i wasn't a bog and plus we had
other guys on our team that times that
were better than me so i just fed them
the ball
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports